cette diagonale jacqueline maillan
exemple war et éclaire pas mal eh bien
c'était une sorte comme d'ailleurs vous
avec michel roux et les carpentier là et
c'était la même robe de ram avait
retrouvé l'ambiance des carpentier ont
été très heureux c'était très simple ça
et puis alors il ya quelqu'un d'autre
qui est sur scène mis en scène par vous
aussi décidément vous arrêtez pas ça me
plaît bien
c'est jean jacques devaux mise ancien
pivot
voilà ce qu'on fait sur les bancs de la
classe l'émission avec la et voilà il
m'a demandé ce que furent mises en scène
c'est à cela qu'il a écrit il ya 21h15
alors vous vous reviendrez sur scène en
septembre 2006 impliquer une fois il m'a
dit tu veux jouer la prochaine pièce je
les lui et il formidable ça avec
isabelle mergault un signal de chirurgie
esthétique
ce parfait et s'appelle si c'était à
refaire
et c'est vrai enfin je joue le texte de
quelqu'un d'autre
je suis excité comme une puce mai
sa variété à la rentrée c'est quoi votre
rêve pierre aujourd'hui je reviens jouer
avec un avec un homme parce que j'ai pas
j'ai beaucoup joué avec bon lâchait il
ya un formidable j'ai beaucoup travaillé
qu'ils aimeraient bien jouer avec
quelqu'un qui ferait mon père avec un
brasseur ou ou un grand frère avec
bigard d'ailleurs champlan projet
travaille avec bigard et s'avance pas
trop et bigard pas prêt encore mais on
se cherche